Oh light blue military trousers I got
like green military so I'm obviously not
who is the better kind of military I
think everyone will agree Green is
obviously superior to this so I don't
know I don't know I guess we'll see I
guess we'll see I guess we'll see do I
need to change the rules or anything
make it hard can you change the settings
or something yeah in the little checkbox
thing oh you're you're the captain now
mark you have to do it all right so it's
nightmare nightmare
oh good nightmare be every room is just
a room that locks and kills you wait
what is it what does pyramid mean I want
more vigor the lower you get on
nightmare here we go skip baskets Duncan
Duncan I just put a bunch up there and
stack the boots in the good look oh hey
guess who's game crashed do you like my
shirt do you like to [ __ ] ugly shirt
I've ever seen from generation to
generation from my dad God it should
have stopped how many people peed on
that shirt
I really feel left out I'm not kidding
experience Oh fine we're leaving we're
leaving we're leaving geez smack your
legs go ask man Jared you don't ask a
lady where her legs of God I just did
hey there we go I have no manners she's
just gonna delay did he was like well I
did if you were just like exactly what
happened but okay I I except that's what
you think that happened
you can think that's what happened you
keep that in your head I'm inviting you
accept it it literally can't launch the
game and there's nothing for me to even
task manager' to death get your head out
of your ass and click the game
I send you an invite get down
and that's thanks thank you another one
another one oh wow that's getting it
that's really cleared it right up we'd
all have was the problem was that you
had invited me and I was just not
willing to accept your love that's what
I thought it was I knew it it was
entirely my fault and I just want to say
thank you for for continuing to try and
look the way commitments here we go hey
I could shoot hoops and stuff guys have
you seen this the who did you know
there's a big hoop and a little hoop
I'm just spamming boots man I'm not here
for bigger a little anything I'm just
you then you are the better person
the little or the hoop the bigger the
penis hey look at my pants are look at
my pants look at my vision you appear be
wearing shoes which I'm pretty sure is
against the rules oh and you're also
wearing a like a tank top thing which
I'm pretty sure you didn't oh oh I'm
sure that you just wanted me going boobs
flapping in the wind that's what you
would want isn't it Bob Bob [ __ ]
ruined it grab a shoe and let's go I'm
only walking on this playthrough let's
go River skull has deemed you worthy I
feel like that it goes up because
gravity is [ __ ] or am i right by the
way it's on nightmare mode so I think
yeah I don't know what that means but it
doesn't seem good you know is trying to
make wine but then was embarrassed I
stopped roasting me I'm just trying to
get my my do see that sure I save your
shoe I saved your shoe yo your boot went
in okay I appreciate that wait how would
this kill you we've seen this it doesn't
kill it makes Kirkwood's
oh I feel like that's pretty kilee
that's very really yeah as far as
killing goes as far as giving goes
that's a 10 take an egg slicer cheese
slicer thingy is that gonna do that
again
it's up there it's up there no no it's
fine it's gonna kill you it's up there
oh well see your friends oh god oh god
I'm in here now and I don't I yep yeah
whoa God hey how's it going my feet and
20 health for that oh my gos all right
I'm pretty sure we can navigate this one
all right what you want to do yeah yeah
oh she's a species oh cool it's the
river that one I have a funny feeling
that we're not gonna make it through
this and not because of my incompetence
but because of others
incompetence you assume that I'm
incompetent just to boots here you don't
need to bat spruce the incompetence
you almost got Wiley coyote I did not
almost hey you guys want to see a room
yeah go for it yeah whatever
see total total deprivation all I see is
a liar
yeah now two of us seem to have two
boots and one of us seems to be a [ __ ]
oh you [ __ ]
yeah something like that
a [ __ ] I am not dead guys guys who is
the greatest ever in the history of
forever
it's this guy me that would be avenged
sevenfold Oh Frick you pushed me into it
that's not a guy that's a band
hi mr. sevenfold would beg to differ
douchebag I'm out of yours yeah so what
do you have to slow yeah see see oh oh
oh oh the fact that the interesting has
so little
shoes versus one shoes such an odd
insult but it cuts so deep for some
reason this the interesting thing
happening here has so little did with
weather that take up my tape so good I
don't know that's that's the kind of
comedy I've been called at a particular
in the past was bragging about their to
moon so look at me I'm gonna go on
record to say that I found two rooms
that after I have to look at the Irish
to keep I you broke up halfway through
there but I knew something about rooms
and luck of the Irish and I believe you
I'll show you luck of the Irish oh my
goodness this is a death room here this
is open it's fine it's a pit of water
yeah don't go in and stop being scared
of things really I really didn't need to
throw my shoe in there at all that was a
mistake
can I have this one thing thanks buddy
thank you Bob yeah I'm good
that's not a good room okay okay okay
okay wait final exit what I found the
exit twice now I told you to stick with
me oh my god Bob guys guys I want to be
part of the party over here yeah yeah
guys my score is 29 is that good my
scores 369 mine 260 that doesn't sound
right how was mine possibly solo when
I'm clearly so superior well maybe if
you were not talking so much more
exploring you would have done better
that's my only coping mechanism for how
sad I am this happened to you guys what
is happening this is normal Mark's just
acting he's fine he's just a cute thing
he doesn't show up you [ __ ] idiot shut
your [ __ ] mouth right now
[ __ ] your talk hole shut your crying
orifice shut your crying teeth bill bear
trap right now you just cry internally
and then leave it at then should your
milk drinker big baby drink whole milk
it's worse for you cuz it's not like
it's good for your bones
it comes from cows boreback less sure
they but if you were to consume anything
that came from cows I would go I would
just go good Steakhouse leave me with my
burgers and fries are we going again or
what's happening your eyes you're king
of the castle hero so click on a little
check mark e thing and change some
settings well let's see how many
hoopty-hoops we can get yeah I like hoop
to use ok this is a five times pyramid
on nightmare with no mini-map and no
lavage Jesus your eyes map holy Oh
oh we're so good yeah we have there's no
mini-map all right we're in a corner
yeah you're just gonna have to guess
your shoe back yes yeah I know
I know how the game wait so why is you
back why two times damage that's
probably gonna kill us all
not two times radius two times times it
goes two times no no no no what two
times damage means no no all right we
gotta get a shoe like yeah order here
we're gonna lose some shoes mark keep
throwing your shoes
keep throwing mark mark wants you Mishu
too
I shoot I'll shoot you I see I shoot
three I thought you is you I thought you
said this is a nightmare
oh okay doesn't even know how to light a
fire
look at this idiot with the exit why is
he sitting there those are fake
alligator yeah yeah Shawn Moo's boss hey
you guys want to see how to beat the
alligators yeah I do got them wow wow
wow yeah that's the trick that's the
boot trick that's a little trick I
learned the other day it's pretty good
hey friend
come from what you say what are you
doing guys Mark's body is slowly sinking
so is yours
oh yeah just way further down wait was
that is that I get hole yeah yeah it's a
hole join
the bandages wait bro bro listen though
for real okay okay just doing that on
the go XOR how are you doing yeah well
so you you basically get what you've not
mark yeah get the get the pitch shifter
knob and like just jam on it and you can
pitch you can actively pitch shift it I
hate everything that's happening how's
it going you guys having a good time
[Music]